or Ukrainian President Vladimir solenski
says there will be more Ukrainian Flags
in the donbass region in the coming week
after his troops took control of these
strategically important town of Lima
Russia's defense Ministry confirmed the
pullout of its forces
Iman is in the Donetsk region one of
four regions that Russian President
Vladimir Putin proclaimed to be part of
Russia on Friday the recapture of liman
by Ukrainian troops is part of a wider
counter-offensive that Ascend Ukrainian
Ukraine rather retake significant
amounts of territory in the east
raising their flag once again
these images purportedly show Ukrainian
troops taking back control of liman
after the Russian defense Ministry
confirmed its troops withdrawal from the
town
despite how significant superiority in
forces and means the enemy brought in
reserves and continued the offensive due
to the threat of encirclement the Allied
troops were withdrawn from the
settlement of liman to more advantageous
lines
the recapture of the town in Donetsk
comes just 24 hours after Moscow
formalized its illegal annexation of the
region
after what kieving the West branded a
sham referendum
meanwhile close to liman
a local official said dozens were killed
by Russian shelling as they tried to
flee
he branded it a cruel act that can't be
justified
One Survivor spoke of her experience
as we were going along the shooting
started abruptly from our left
the driver told me to get out of the car
fast we got out
we land the ground the shelling
continued we crawled along some rail
tracks
we were shortered
we couldn't even raise our heads even
though I wanted to look at my dad I saw
my dad get shot he was shot in the head
I saw it with my own eyes
13 children and a pregnant woman are
understood to be among the Dead
these images are a reminder but despite
territorial victories the human cost of
the war continues to rise
well meanwhile U.S defense minister
Lloyd Austin said that Ukraine's victory
in liman would be a strategic headache
for Russia as it seeks to hold off the
counter-offensive elsewhere
we're very encouraged by what we're
seeing right now even sits astride the
supply lines of the other Russians and
they've used those routes to uh to push
men and material down to the South and
to the west and without those routes
it'll be more difficult so this presents
a sort of a dilemma for uh for the
Russians going forward
or DW correspondent materials building
is in the capital Kiev Matthias a
Ukrainian flag was raised on the
outskirts of liman on Saturday do we
know if Ukraine has now retaken the
entire town
yeah what we've been hearing from the
Russian Ministry of defense is that they
have withdrawn from uh the town so uh
yes Ukraine Leman is now on the
Ukrainian control
matissus is being sold as an important
strategic victory for Ukraine is that
the case
yeah liman is the first major settlement
that Ukraine has been able to take back
in uh the donbass now if we look back at
the March this year end of March
beginning of April when the Russian
forces withdrew from the Kiev region and
the other regions in the north uh
uh they were concentrating all their
efforts on the donbass at the time and
they were bringing all their Firepower
and all their Manpower into the donbus
and they were advancing slowly and uh
there but they claimed that recapturing
the whole of tombas was their target
their main objective of of that phase of
the war they haven't been able to take
the whole off the donbas but they were
able to advance and now this is the
first time that things are reversed that
Ukraine has been taking back territory
in these areas that are the core also of
what Russia has illegally annexed last
Friday so this is a major victory
symbolically because it is the first
town of the donbus but it's also
strategically important because it opens
a new way for Ukraine further into the
territories of the donbass of of the
luhansk region notably
um with possibly severed Donetsk and
Lucy chanskying the next big targets the
two major cities that Russia captured in
May and we of course don't know how easy
it will be but it is for them the
Russians are regrouping now whether they
will be able to form a new line of
defense at the moment things look pretty
chaotic but that's probably something to
be expected at this stage we will see
that later but it's definitely adding
momentum to the Ukrainian Advance after
they have been able to take back almost
all of the kharkif regime yeah this
latest Victory seems to confirm that
idea of Ukrainian momentum but how high
a price is Ukraine paying for these
victories in terms casualties
while Ukraine is not disclosing the
number of casualties we have been
hearing that the casualties were pretty
high they are always higher in offensive
operations than in defensive operations
we have only estimates but
during the maybe hottest phase of the
war in the donbass when Russia was
really using all of its Firepower
zelinski once talked about one or two
hundred soldiers being killed a day now
you can do the math even if it's it's
become less after that after June it it
shifted a little bit
the thing shifted a little bit and
Russia didn't use the same amount of
Firepower but you cannot several dozens
a day several maybe into the hundreds a
day and seven months you can do the math
it's we we must expect Ukraine to have
lost several tens of thousands of
soldiers we have the Russians who are
saying that Ukraine has lost 50 000
soldiers now these things because are of
course something to be treated with
caution because the the the numbers that
one gives about their enemies losses are
tend to be higher but this war of course
comes at a great cost to Ukraine
dwe correspondent Matthias billinger in
Keith thanks so much